[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM HWANG: I called
the nuclear power plant
and basically asked them whether
or not I could do a tour.
And they eventually
asked me, who are you?
Where do you come from?
And I was like, I'm just really
interested in seeing the plant.
We pretty much got a no.
So what I did was worked
with a couple of friends.
I had to put together
a fancy-sounding name
and a fancy-sounding
organization,
and we tried again.
And we got in.
We weren't sure whether or not
it was going to work at all.
I wasn't even sure
whether or not
they would take one
look at the site
and say, well, that's
not a real organization.
Because at that time,
it really wasn't.
We were sort of like,
well, we kind of
pulled off this weird trick.
How many other
places could we get
into if we started doing this?
Hey, are you Dave?
DAVE HYAMS: Hi, Tim.
Welcome to Sutro Tower.
TIM HWANG: Hey,
thanks for having us.
DAVE HYAMS: Glad
to show you around.
TIM HWANG: Thanks.
I'm fascinated by
Sutro Tower, because it
looks so out of place.
There's these beautiful
rolling hills and this fog,
and then there's just
this, like, enormous,
protruding antenna in
the middle of the city.
DAVE HYAMS: Here we go.
TIM HWANG: Infrastructure
is something
that your tax dollars go
to pay for quite often.
But if you just walked
up as an average citizen
and tried to ask whether
or not you can get in,
it's usually fenced off.
It's impossible to
access these places.
Kinda like, who's
this weird guy who
wants to drive hundreds of miles
to see this thing that no one
ever asks to visit ever?
So when we started
doing more tours,
people started to
get in touch, saying,
this is a great idea--
how do I join up?
And so now, we've got a
couple groups all over.
So we have a chapter in
London, a chapter in New York,
and a chapter in LA.
Cities-- they're
incredibly dense places.
And in your everyday
life, you actually
only end up seeing a tiny,
tiny percentage of it.
Turning on the light bulb,
driving across the bridge,
biking to work-- there's a whole
team of people that makes sure
it works every single
time you do that action.
It's just very enjoyable to
appreciate the world around you
when you have the
opportunity to do so.
You know, I'm always
really excited by the fact
that when people
start doing the tours,
they may come because it's
really fun to go visit,
but once you're there, you
start thinking about, well, this
is such a great resource.
Why isn't more investment
going into it, right?
Or why is it broken in this way?
Or why does it have
all these problems?
And so I think it's really
important that people
kind of learn about the
state of infrastructure
and hopefully get motivated
to do something about it.
We live in a culture
which is very,
you know, move fast and
iterate, particularly
here in San Francisco
in the tech industry.
But you can't just
hack a bridge.
You can't just throw something
up, and then see what happens,
and then debug it later, right?
When a bridge goes into place,
it's pretty much got to work.
If it doesn't, really
bad things could happen.
And essentially we were really
fascinated by that idea,
like the idea that we're
building stuff that will
last for hundreds of years.
SPEAKER 1: Please check
out this next video.
SPEAKER 2: You can see the
neon lights, the 40-story tall
casinos.
And then right beneath that
is this dark and gray world,
where people are just
trying to survive.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks for watching
and be sure to subscribe
to Seeker Stories.